you know people think to tend to think
of YouTube as a platform for kids it
seems like it's it's gaining more
traction these days it's been around for
so many years that people are accepting
it more as a launching pad but I think
it's still underrated for a lot of
filmmakers they tend to go more with
Vimeo or different things and what would
you tell the people who say you know
YouTube is just sort of a kids of
platform or it hasn't really evolved yet
maybe you watch her film I mean this is
a Cinderella story with a very very
particular twist it's a modern
Cinderella story like I said this story
would not have been possible pre-youtube
how could it be right he got discovered
because of this thing called YouTube and
Neil just Neil was actually had had it
with the editions and he couldn't find
anyone and he was really he turned to
YouTube that's that's a fact that's what
happened
so no though you can't dismiss you -
it's there it's big I mean this story is
based on that that's it couldn't have
happened without it and for all of the
positives with YouTube there's still
that negative part where trolls of all
sorts can and on and say whatever how
much of whatever backlash is left
because I think our nails definitely
proven himself to be excellent but how
much backlash do you think comes from
people wishing that they had been
discovered so I wonder if that's a huge
component of it the backlash that he
still gets yeah I think there's a lot of
that and there's a lot of very hardcore
Steve Perry fans I I think that's the
thing about journeys their fans are so
hardcore I mean they really really
follow the band and they're very
attached to them it's a very personal
thing and personal to Steve Perry as
well so I think the backlash comes from
that and yeah I think a little bit of
snark that you know why not mean why him
and why did they have to import him from
a different country I mean there's so
many people you know here who could sing
as well or whatever I think yeah but you
know you have to realize it's the
Internet right it's the world there's so
much the good and the bad and
a lot of bad a lot of snark and you
can't really and Arnelle says this you
can't get into it you can't drown or not
you'll drown right you can't listen to
all the voices out there on the Internet
there's so many people who will always
say you know not very positive things
right I thought you did an excellent job
of showing him just a few brief moments
where he just slowly sort of admitted
there are people that maybe don't want
me to succeed but there's so many more
that do yes and that that fueled him and
even though in those moments where he
said I want to go home he still made it
out there and performed beautifully yeah
but I don't understand his impulse to
say I just want to go home because when
you see those people and um at the end
like you're performing for two hours
you're giving it your all it's tiring
it's at the end of you know you can see
him it's like he's drained
I think he's animated but you know ice
energized but enervated at the same time
so it's just two things that are sort of
clashing within him and and yet the next
thing he has to do it again so I
understand the impulse is like just let
me go home I love it but can I just go
for a while I think and that's why they
built in the tours now they build like
little breaks for him to go home he
actually goes back to Manila and takes
the rest which i think is great then
it's good for everyone
you